uh have you have you had any issues like
adjusting to the streaming world or do
you feel like it it benefits artists
like you that's independent that can
just kind of drop freely if you will
man i'm one of them people like this bro
i'm like uh
i'm not a stuck in my ways type of king
right
i hustle the dinosaur way
the modern way
and the future way so it i mean i love
it i just embrace it i still press up my
physical copies in my wax for the djs
that like wax and wax sales for pretty
good money these days so yeah people
still buy vinyl it's like almost like as
a collector they'd almost rather buy the
vinyl than the cd because it feels like
um
there's people buying vinyl don't even
have a turntable to play it on they just
want to have it agreed agreed and um
so yeah that's that's where i met and
then like the things with the streams
you know like like i say the only
downfall to the stream you know like i'm
not i'm not one of them og haters like
uh
i'm like i [ __ ] with the new cats the
new artist you know my only concern with
the streams is like this how i compare
it right i compared a stream to this
you know how back in the days you could
go to a music store and listen to the
whole album yeah you should go to sam
goody and right you can jam it whatever
whatever all right if you didn't buy it
you didn't get that sale right like the
pro the artist didn't get that sale so
if you go to a car lot and you test
drive a car
and you don't buy it the guy who's
selling the car doesn't get credit
for you test driving the car right it
gets credit for yourself so just the way
that they converted to like yeah this
many streams just means you're platinum
right but
a sample to me is still not it's like
you can't lower the goal post that's how
i look at it no matter where no matter
what right like any other business if
you sell pizza
if you only sell 20 pizzas man you only
sold 20 pizzas well if you think about
it like with the playlist world it's
like you might throw a new playlist on
that spotify feed you whether it's like
rap cabbage or whatever
and even if the song plays for 30
seconds you don't [ __ ] with it you hit
next on the playlist it still counts as
a stream right
so it's it it's like a
sometimes a person that's able to be
like oh yeah i went platinum i got this
many streams and it creates a big head
like a lot also like you'll really know
if it's working if you can sell hard
tickets correct because there's a lot of
these artists who stream big numbers but
they can't go on tour yeah so it's so
it's so
like i'm like on the fence with like
just like a hundred percent like oh i
love it like it's dope that people all
around the world can hear your music
from the push of a button but when you
can also upload [ __ ] exactly button so
it's exactly back in the day you had to
go press up cds find distribution right
to get like your [ __ ] all over the
country in a record store agreed man so
now it's like i just hit there's no
middleman yeah so like
i embrace it i'm one of them people i
adapt man what's going on you know
plaques like i love i love like in my
house and my studios i got plaques and
stuff on the wall that just inspires me
man you know what i mean so